est-ce que Christian Belgie c'est-à-dire
vous oui chantez autre chose que du
Claude François non
[Musique]
non laisse une chance à notre
amour
la
[Applaudissements]
chance un magicien voilà vous AZ la voix
et puis vous avez l'illusion c'est
Claude voilà tout simplement en de
mors c'est une illusion c'est la magie
etés
je m'appelle Christian Belgie B je chant
frçois bon ce soir je suis à côté de moi
bon pour les 20 ans de la disparition de
Claude bon je travaille comme un fou
furieux depuis déjà pas mal d'années
mais spécialement ce mois de mars 98 je
suis allé au cimetière tout à l'heure
c'est empreint de plein de
de de tendresse aussi de la part des
fans je me suis aperçu
aujourd'hui chose que je ne savais pas
que les fans aussi m'aimait
et ben j'en ai un peu pleuré tout à
l'heure tellement ça m'a fait chaud au
cœur suite
monsieur
chou je ne sais plus com en
faire qui te dit que je suis comme elle
que j'aime toujours les chons qui parour
et
ti de chacun depis depuis 11 ans que je
suis fan de Claude depuis 3 ans que je
suis fan de
Christian je ne peux pas me passer de ça
c'est pas possible j'en ai besoin c'est
comme c'est comme de la drogue un peu
c'est un peu comme un Dieu qui donne du
soleil quand il y a des nuages
quoiog pour l'un et l'autre est-ce que
c'est toujours cette période la période
du mois de mars donc de l'anniversaire
de Claude François que vous êtes le plus
demander
ou c'est c'est particulier cette
année bon cette année c'est c'est un
petit peu plus particulier bien sûr mais
moi j'ai quand même cette chance de
travailler toute l'année et ce depuis
pas mal de temps
maintenant depuis combien de temps j'ai
commencé il y a 18 ans et vous depuis
combien de temps en professionnel depuis
92 est-ce que l'on peut dire que vous
êtes des sausides Claude François parce
que vous l'êtes non non pour vous non
alors donc vous non définitivement et
vous non pour moi non plus je n'aime pas
tellement la le le le le mot Susie en
général parce qu'il est il est galvodé
bon il est il est mais vous avez quand
même maintenant vous travaillez quand
même le look vous êtes un vous avez pris
la même couleur de cheveux oui c'est
vrai mais euh tu vois qu'il y a une
épulation non oui aussi bah oui mais je
je claude était également bon épilé bon
et puis euh je crois que me souvenir que
que que au début de sa carrière il était
quand même d'une nature de cheveux
beaucoup plus
foncé comment est venu pour vous cette
cette passion ou ce métier bon sur un
sur un espèce de Paris bon en 80 bon
j'ai voulu monter un spectacle hommage
mais c'était plus un un Paris je ne
pensais pas que ça marcherait que ça
accrocherait et de fil en aiguille bon
je me suis retrouvé sur des plateaux de
télévision et au fur à mesure des années
j'ai peaufiné euh le le le personnage
mais euh comme un comment dirais-je
comme un comédien
euh je je ne cherche pas
l'identification qu'est-ce que vous
faisiez comme métier il y a 18 ans h il
y a 18 ans j'étais euh je venais de
vendre une boîte de nuit que j'avais en
Normandie et précédemment à cette boîte
de nuit j'étais clairdissier donc
quelque chose de d'opposé ah oui
absolument rien à voir rien à voir rien
à voir aujourd'hui ce métier vous l'avez
avez toujours ou vous ne vivez que de
des spectacles je ne je ne vis que des
spectacles actuellement mais alors qui
vous les demande bon les comités des
fêtes comités d'entreprise des soirées
privées des discothèques des animations
de magasins et le métier que je fais
maintenant bon me permet de de faire
vivre ma famille euh et vous avez
combien en moyenne par par mois c'est
c'est très variable mais bon une moyenne
de de 30 35 35000 ouais à peu près
comment les gens réagissent au cours de
de ces soirées lorsqu'ils lorsqu'ils
vous
voi mais il y a toujours un accueil
formidable bon il y a l'étonnement au
départ quand on arrive sur scène bon al
ils viennent pour qui pour Claude
François ou pour vous j'ai cette
sensation de de de de mélange de de
communion entre eux et moi avec un
mélange d'images mais ça peut être
troublant dans ce que vous racontez non
parce que comme je sais aussi quitter
quitter le le le
l'emploi bon à la fin d'un spectacle je
ne reste jamais habillé je ne reste
jamais maquillé je redeviens Christian
et donc il n y a pas de confusion
possible vous êtes marié vous avez des
enfants alors je suis divorcé bon j'ai
deux grandes filles 23 ans et 20 ans
alors comment comment elles vivent cela
al quand elles étaient plus jeunes elles
vivaient très très mal bon du genre même
n ne vient pas nous chercher à l'école
pourquoi elles avaient honte euh pas
honte mais
euh je pense que plein d'enfants dont
les parents font partie de ce métier euh
essaent de se créer un paravant une une
protection bon maintenant elles sont
grandes et je crois qu'elles sont fières
de leur papa mais elles trouvent ça
peut-être un gar à 23 ans non non ah non
pas du tout pas du tout est-ce que
Christian Belgie c'est-à-dire vous oui
euh chantez autre chose que du Claude
François
non
non non bi je enfin si je chante comme
tout le monde bon ben des des des tous
les air qu'on aime bien bon chanteur de
salle de bain quoi
bon les trucs qu'on entend à la radio ou
ou les disque ancien qu'on aime bien
mais bon au niveau de la scène je ne
fais que les chansons de Claude François
vous n'avez jamais dans le fond voulu
être chanteur ce n'était pas une une
envie d'enfant alors bon c'est vrai que
j'ai toujours voulu monter sur scène
toujours voulu faire
être dans le spectacle mais pas
forcément la
chanson par voilà c'est un peu différent
pour vous alors c'est un peu différent
disons que au départ j'ai j'ai commencé
par écrire des chansons ce que je fais
toujours aujourd'hui et puis ces
chansons je l'ai chanté dans les cafés
là donc vous êtes avant tout vous auteur
compositeur voilà tout à fait j'ai
toujours aimé ça et j'avais un père qui
pai à son âme mais qui avait horreur
pour lui c'était j'étais un j'étais un
un bohémien c'était pas sérieux il
fallait faire des études avant tout
alors j'ai j'ai fait des études de
comptable et et voilà j'ai jamais su
compé en fait est-ce que vous avez
exercé ce métier de comptable pas un
jour pas une fois pas une fois par
contre en réaction je me suis dit je
veux ce métier je ne veux que ça et je
le je l'ai fait parce que justement je
j'ai toujours voulu lui prouver je pense
que tous les garçons sont comme ça vis
de leur père que tu vois PAP pas je peux
réussir quelque chose j'ai souffert
beaucoup de la solitude j'avais des
parents qui étaient toujours en voyage
et ce donc j'étais très seul et et
quelque part on y viendra sans doute
mais Claude François est un personnage
qui m'a beaucoup aidé parce que c'est
quelque part un maître à penser et
presque un père pour moi parce qu'il
avait cette présence que mon propre père
n'avait pas je me rappelle plus de cette
période mais ma mère m'a plusieurs fois
raconté que j'étais devant la télévision
et que je regardais un spectacle que
c'était Claude François cette épo je le
savais pas en fait je lui ai dit maman
plus tard je ferai ce métier là quand
vous faites un spectacle je comprenne
bien vous interprétez Claude François et
un peu de vos chansons ou uniquement
Claude François et parfois uniquement
vos chansons je fais pas du Claude
François
systématique parce que j'ai bon j'ai des
chanson mais comme j'ai la tête de
l'emploi pour moi c'est pas difficile de
chaner de claud François or quand j'ai
commencé en 92 à sor mon premier 45
tours tout le monde m'a dit c'est
dommage que vous ne dansiez pas que vous
n'ayez pas des danseuses que vous ne
chanz pas Claude François que fa pas des
spectacles claud François al quand ça
venait au niveau du public j'avoue que
j'ai au départ j'ai mal réagi cétazv niz
vous en tant que c'était disons que ça
venait c'était une entrave à ma carrière
et j'ai voulu m'en défendre parce que
parce que je me suis dit mais je suisis
je je suis quand un compositeur je vis
chanter mes propres titres mais il y a
aussi la demande de plus en plus
pressente et de plus en plus forte des
organisateurs de dire on voudrait des
spectacles on veut que vous chantiez du
Claude François je l'ai fait au départ
j'étais habillé en
tenue de ville je vais le dire et où je
chantais d'une manière un peu figé sans
doute les cloches sonnaient belle belle
belle et alors les gens étaient contents
ils applaudissaient mais il y avait un
petit on venait à la table on disait
pourquoi vous faites pas vos cheveux
plus blan pourquoi vous faites pas c
cela et au départ à tout ça au fond même
je disais non c'est pas moi tout ça mais
je me suis rendu compte que quelque part
je leur cassais un rêve et j'ai je j'ai
senti que le public s'éloigné de moi al
je me suis dit qui a raison c'est public
ou c'est moi je dois écouter qui moi ou
les gens qui ont cette délicatesse de
venir me voir c'est dire que votre votre
carrière finalement de chanteur a pu a
pu s'épanouir à travers lorsque vous
avez fait des concessions oui exact il
faut faire beaucoup de concessions dans
ce mtier je t'apprends rien j'en fais
terriblement mais je dois reconnaître
que s'il y avait pas eu un Claude
François il y aurait jamais eu d'indest
non plus donc je je c'est blessant ça
c'est difficile à vivre certains jours
ça peut être difficile à vivre pour être
très honnête oui il y a un passage
obligé et ce passage lui c'est Claude
François vous vous le voyez comme un
signe du destin voilà je l'ai accepté
comme ça et je le je le je le vis comme
ça je l'ai accepté oui je veux dire
quelque part dans la vie le plus dur et
où c'est de pouvoir accepter
l'inacceptable et c'est ce qui prend le
plus de temps c'est ça qu'on doit mourir
et je l'ai je le je je je l'ai vécu
comme une crise pendant quelques années
et je j'ai accepté accepter
l'inacceptable ça veut dire que alindes
à un moment donné capitule accepte de
n'avoir du succès qu'à travers Claude
François accepte le succès à travers ce
que les gens lui demande et j'ai dit
Claude maintenant tu me montres le
chemin parce que moi je suis qu'un
ignorant oui je suis à mes claviers je
fais de la musique c'est certain je
compose mais les compositions sont là
aucune mes autre disques n'en veut
aucune mais elles sont toutes là il y a
des album entiers qui sont prêts
d'alindes du pur àindes est-ce que ça
sortira un jour peut-être jamais je n'en
sais rien tout à l'heure vous vous
disiez qu'il vous avait aidé que Claude
François vous avait aidé à certains
moments de de votre vie tous les jours
mais de quelle manière je parle à Claude
ah bon avant de monter sur scène je
demande à Claude de me donner ce courage
de de chanter à quel moment vous avez
commencé à
entretenir finalement cette cette
conversation avec lui ça a toujours été
toujours c'est un compagnon spirituel
oui tout à fait vous le costume que vous
que vous portez c'est le costume de
Claude François en fait comment ça c'est
le costume oui donc en fait le le je je
connais la la présidente du fan club en
Belgique et souvent s'est vu ensemble et
un jour dans une soirée comme ça elle me
disait mais tu sais que j'ai des
costumes de Claude François ici tu veux
les voir vra les vrais costumes qu'elle
avait racheté dans des conditions
j'expliquerai pas et euh donc après son
décès ça t'intéresserait de les essayer
et alors on s'est rendu compte que
c'était ça donc vous avez tous les
plusieurs costumes de des fris vous
voilà c'est la totale les boots la mise
le machin donc ce qui fait que c'est
lour à porter quand même ça c'est dis
donc un sacré héritage vous le feriez ça
de porter les vrais c'est oui ce mot est
juste c'est un héritage dont j'ai pris
c'est pourquoi j'expliquis
l'inacceptable dont j'ai pris le passif
actif à la fois pour ne rien manquer sur
ma chaîne Inna Mireille Guma
abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche